even before these votes are counted the
results of this presidential election in
uzbekistan are all but certain incumbent
president shavkat mirzayev is expected
to win another five-year term as there
is no real opposition running against
him despite that these voters are hoping
to bring about whatever change they can
can give you leader the next five years
i would like to see living standards
raised higher salaries no poverty better
employment and housing that would make
us all happy
mirzayev came to power in 2016 after the
death of his mentor islam keremov who
ruled the central asian country for 27
years
with a history of authoritarian rule the
country has never really had a truly
democratic election
he's the best of a pretty bad lot
there's not no one has been able or has
been allowed to emerge to be of a true
uh
to to be able to mount the true
challenge to mr miziov
with everything that i have said the
positive trends you have to obviously
admit that the economic indicators have
slipped simply because i've coveted 19.
the pandemic has hit uzbekistan's
economy hard raising unemployment and
the cost of living especially in rural
areas even the problems
the main problems are in the regions not
the capital in the capital everything is
more or less fine people have water gas
electricity in the other areas
unfortunately there's a lack of all of
this
mirzyev has been credited with helping
to boost tourism and ties with foreign
powers but the country now has to
navigate new boundaries with new
neighbors in afghanistan the taliban the
u.s is still interested in continuing
its military relations with with uh with
uzbekistan and obviously russia is
continuing to exercise
south power economic power etc uh the
the big question is whether you know the
situation in
afghanistan will spill over to these
countries there's a lot of concern that
they at least stay secular and do not
fall prey to the uh extremist influences
as mirza yev went to cast his own vote
at a polling station on the outskirts of
the capital tashkent his chances of
winning remain around 90 percent
leah harding al jazeera